hello happy Sunday let's start this
morning shall we at hearing from the
government a few moments ago I spoke to
the Northern Ireland secretary Chris
Heaton Harris
what is the plan on tackling small boats
well I mean there's a whole host of
actions that we are taking and need to
take and what the Prime Minister said
it's one of his
um key priorities is to stop the small
boats what the premise is saying is that
we also need some legislation on top of
what we are doing
um so we can make sure that people who
come to this country illegally are
returned very quickly and I that's I
what I expect to see in the legislation
so just on the legislation is it right
the reports this morning that if you
come to the UK illegally then you're
going to be banned from claiming Asylum
I believe so yes so that's going to be
it's black and white legislation is very
black and white and how are you going to
change the law
um I don't know I mean it's not my
portfolio but um we get a cabinet
briefing uh
pre-announcement and we've been talking
about this for quite some time so I
don't know the actual words of the
legislation but I'm very I know it has
to be extremely clear because
um like in my own portfolio of Northern
Ireland I know if you're not clear
um people are picking it and we're
expecting it Tuesday is that right I've
got no idea okay
um so what will happen to these people
then if you you know arrive on a small
boat you're banned from claiming Asylum
what will happen to them well it's going
to go back to their own country they're
going to be taken to Rwanda yeah well
quite possibly all of those things or
any of those things but also there is um
part of this is actually making sure
that we have a very strong and good
relationship with France which the
Primus has been building because there
are you know we need France also to help
us in this situation part of it's also
other European countries through which
these people travel or trafficked
um before they before they come here so
um part of this is also you could say in
our International Aid budget uh where we
are trying to make sure people economies
are built uh properties so people don't
feel the need to travel from the
original country so it's a whole batch
of different things but should people
come to this country illegally
um then
um yeah they will be returned or sent to
someone like Randa which is a legal
scheme proven to be so in the high court
as we move forward
um so obviously to stay in this country
and to claim asylum in the future you're
going to need to do so for a legal route
now there are clear legal routes to
claim Asylum if you're from Ukraine
Afghanistan or Hong Kong if you're not
for one of those countries what is the
legal route yeah well there'll be I mean
I'm quite sure there'll be more safe and
legal routes and that's why
um you know and that's why we have them
and you're quite right they've been
proven to work
um and actually the level of illegal uh
Asylum illegal uh migrants coming to
this country the way the number that
come in of course all sorts of ripples
even in my own constituency where we
have a a couple of the hotels that uh
house
um uh the the people who come across in
small boats have caused quite some
ripples in local communities that have
been very comfortable with the level of
migration that we've had up until this
point and so reports in the community
we've also seen some quite aggressive
approaches
and yeah people get there are lots of
people who are triggered in all sorts of
ways
by this level of illegal immigration
into our country so we do need to deal
with this you mentioned there that there
should be more legal routes into the UK
which feels crucial to me because the
point I was trying to get at is that for
many people if you're from I don't know
Syria or another war-torn country there
may not be a legal route to get to the
UK other than the small boats so is that
something you're going to try and change
well I mean that is obviously for the
Prime Minister and the Home Secretary
but um they're also all the different
skilled routes that for school migrants
coming to the country as well yeah we're
talking about Asylum Seekers here we
were talking people who may not be able
to you know come through the normal
economic and skilled routes people who
work fluid and it's not it really isn't
for me as Northern nine secretary to say
what what they should be that's you know
for the policy makers in the home office
and for the Prime Minister
um but the safe and legal Roots way has
been proven to work as you say a whole
host of occasions over a hundred
thousand Hong Kong Chinese uh
already knows ukrainians in that
community that have come here and been
truly welcomed I have a I still have a
hotel um full of people from Afghanistan
who who uh who fled right at the last
minute from
um Kabul
um you know just 18 months ago
um who have been truly welcomed into the
those local communities and so it's
really important that we need to get
this right and you think that
expanded so that other people who are
not from the countries that I mentioned
um should be having I think this that
safe and legal Roots is is absolutely
the way forward and we should welcome
people who come through those routes
okay
I want to talk brexit but
professors are under real pressure right
now in back moot reports on the Sunday
Times that Rishi sunak is set to
announce billions of pounds more funding
for the defense budget and next weekend
when he visits the US is that right
um again a speculation that's a
pre-budget and you you know better than
I do you'll have loads of politicians
sat here just before a budget from the
government who can't say a word about
the forthcoming budget but what I do
know is that uh in Northern Ireland
there's a fantastic company to us who
are making the end times that have been
doing such a good job for Ukrainian
forces
um uh on the battlefield in in Ukraine
and I know that we as a country and the
Prime Minister has completely
make behind making sure that we continue
our support
okay very much well we'll we'll have
more but on Ukraine in the program as
well some interviews from uh key coming
up too now I want to talk brexit with
your Northern Ireland uh hat on um
unionists of course are very unhappy
about any idea that Northern Ireland
could be treated differently from the
rest of the United Kingdom now you must
be having conversations with the dep all
of the time are they going to back the
deal
um well that's really up to them I mean
we're currently are we
I I understand as a as a Euro skeptic um
you know that actually uh eurosceptics
and units have been let down a couple of
times before
um by the protocol and within Theresa
May's deal uh as well and so
um in in getting to the place that we've
got to you know we're very keen to make
sure that people can read all the texts
and you know we publish it early no
one's being bounced into everything
everybody's got the time and space so
some people thought that they were being
bounced into it right we had on the show
last Sunday we had members of the
eurosceptic group uh saying that they
were being bounced into they haven't
been seen illegal facts yeah but um now
they have and now they've had a nearly a
week to digest it and you know there's
still some more time before we get
anywhere near having a vote in the
Commons and I know the ERG style chamber
is I'm former chair of the ERG I I I
welcome its work in this area because um
I want them to be convinced as I am that
this is a really good deal for the
people of Northern Ireland
um and to understand all the
implications of it and so there will be
about them when when's that going to be
um well there'll be a vote at some point
when when people have had proper time to
digest what's in the text you know we're
giving it lots of time and space to
people so the um original question the
dep
um obviously is up to them what they do
but you must have a sense of it you're
having conversations with them right
yeah but this is a I actually think
there are a range oh I know there are a
range of views within the dup themselves
and so
um it's not for me to manage another
party I was
Boris Johnson's Chief whip it was very
difficult just to manage my own so I'm
not going to second guess what a a
another political party will do but
they've asked for clarifications in in a
number of areas and we are going to give
them that clarification there's
technical talks that are ongoing with
all the political parties in Northern
Ireland this coming week about how the
storm won't break will work because
that's a new uh Innovative way of making
sure that you know people do have a
democratic say over some of the rules
that affect them so let's talk about
that shall we because that was one of
the clarifications as you said that some
people are looking for
um it would effectively allow
politicians in Northern Ireland to have
say over new legislation passed in
Brussels
veto or is it just a delaying mechanism
so it
um storm one and the UK raised concern
the legislation is suspended for four
weeks yeah so so yeah but there's so
there is a yeah when the concern is
raised that is when the delay kicks in
and when it goes through the complete
process the UK government can veto
How likely do you think it is that the
UK government will be willing to veto
e-law I think if it was going to affect
Northern Ireland in a significant way we
would veto EU law because the EU have
said the measure can only be used in the
most exceptional circumstances and as a
matter of Last Resort yeah we've said
that it's got to have significant you
know we've used the significant um uh
the word significant because it has to
have you can't be using a veto trivially
but I don't think actually the Northern
Ireland assembly would be using that uh
that uh trivially and I think this is
actually quite a it's a new thing it's a
treaty change it's being written into
Article 13 3A for those that are really
interested of the protocol
um and and that's it's a proper break a
proper veto
um but I I like to think and I having
got to know many of the mlas members of
the legislative assembly in Northern
Ireland that they would only use it
sensibly unionists are also worried
about the extent to which EU law will
still apply in Northern Ireland which of
course matters as the UK diverges from
the EU in the future so you know if
there are future trade deals with our
countries and can you guarantee that
people and businesses in Northern
Ireland will be able to participate that
in those in exactly the same way as the
rest of the UK yeah I think we can and
and also I mean there is so there is
about we're now left with about three
percent of what was existing uh uh EU
law is going to be in place after this
gets adopted and that's the bare minimum
required to allow northernlin businesses
the access they have to the European
single Market because you can't really
guarantee
um that Northern Ireland will be able to
participate in trade trade deals in the
future if you diverge from EU law in
single Market rules at Northern Ireland
you know yeah no no absolutely that's
that's one of the a very uh big
differences between this deal and the
any previous protocol
uh you know various articles that people
thought did the job
um we're also going to um and you're not
worried that this that quote's not going
to be played back to you in like six
months time when the EU says actually no
that's not a Northern Ireland can't
apply for these rules and the trade deal
that you've signed with you know the
states or whatever it is I'm generally
not worried about that okay okay
confident yeah
um at the heart of this of course is the
fact that Northern London is still in
paralysis you know storm one is still
not setting there's no government there
if a deep you don't back the deal if
they still continue to refuse to
participate in the Northern Ireland
assembly what are you going to do yeah
well I mean first that's a theoretical
question I mean I want to get over the
next couple of weeks and hopefully be
able to clarify all the questions that
the dep and actually others in the
unionist community have and indeed
others in the northern political parties
have
um I'd like to think that at that point
we will be able to get the executive up
and running
um but I've already already in fact last
week we were passing legislation through
Parliament uh called the executive
formation act
which allows me to have the opportunity
to call elections at any point during
the next year should that be required
there are other and there are there are
other routes for that we need to do
things on governance if that is the case
however
I'm a glass awful man I believe we can
get this right I think um The Windsor
framework is an Amazing Leap Forward
um I I do think it actually delivers on
all the questions that have been asked
we need to clarify some of those for for
some of the unions Community I'm
absolutely up for doing that is there a
time frame by which if someone isn't up
and running you're going to say right
that's it I need to push the button on
an election no I've learned I've learned
from previous lessons in Northern
Ireland that you don't set time frames
and even if you have one in your mind
you would never give it publicly okay
and now you clearly think this is a good
deal for Northern Ireland and the rest
of the UK I just want to play you what
the Prime Minister said when he
announced the details of the deal let's
have a listen
Northern Ireland is in the unbelievably
special position unique position in the
entire world European continent in
having privileged access not just to the
UK Home Market but also the European
Union single Market nobody else has that
no one
only you guys only here
and that is the prize
can you think of any other countries
that used to have you know the benefit
to that prize as well access to the UK
market and the single yeah I hear your
question and actually it was interesting
I was interested in in this in the
statement that um when the Prime
Minister made a statement on Monday
evening that um Fly cumbrian and and
Scottish nationalists were saying oh we
quite like yeah it sounds like a good
idea like that deal
um but we have the benefits of leaving
the European Union and we've got a uh
the cooperation agreement trading
cooperation agreement with the European
Union
um and now having sorted the protocol
out I believe that Northern Ireland is
in the position that the Prime Minister
uh said uh said it is it's interesting
you mentioned there
um people in Scotland and Wales saying
we quite like the deal that Northern
Ireland has I mean particularly in
Scotland where people voted to remain
can you see that there may be an
argument that actually they should be
able to have the kind of yeah so they
they are gonna we are going to benefit
from as a whole country now from from
leaving the European Union and not
having not having laws imposed on us
that we you have no control over
Scotland as well Northern Ireland was
not in that place because there's always
been some sort of agreement or protocol
that has not allowed Northern Ireland
um to leave the European union now
that's what we are here we are
completing that job and Northern Ireland
by accepting that there is going to be
this three percent of EU laws the bare
minimum will also maintain its you um
position the Prime Minister was
outlining you're a skeptic obviously
it's that made us poorer uh no what the
OBS that predicts both exports and
imports will be 15 lower in the long run
than if the UK had remained in the EU
the bank of England predicts the UK
suffering loss of business investment
worth 29 billion I understand the
arguments about autonomy about democracy
on has it made us poorer you say no I
say no what's your evidence for that my
evidence is that we're we are still a
growing economy we're doing really well
we've had we're the only Parts in the
country in the G7 to have a smaller
economy than pre-pandemic yeah but it
depends on which year you're managing
measuring and and where actually I think
people
it doesn't depend it doesn't depend on
what year you're measuring if you look
at our pre-pandemic economy size we're
the only country that G7 to have a
smaller one so but people
I'm a great believer that this country
has got a much better future that will
grow quicker or having left the European
Union I believe actually we're just
about to prove that and in Northern
Ireland we're going to prove it even
more because of the deal that we've just
struck on under under the Windsor
framework now
um I think it's very difficult to to
measure like with like because of a
whole host of things that have happened
since brexit there was absolutely a
stutter after brexit
um economically but it's very difficult
to measure that because covert then came
very quickly uh the war in Ukraine came
very quickly every country hasn't it not
just ours yeah but in very different
ways in many different ways okay now
you're good friends with Boris Johnson
he has said that the new deal is not
about the UK taking back control it will
act as a drag anchor or Divergence from
the EU and as a result he'll find it
difficult to vote for it have you spoken
to the former prime minister of other
deal yeah I've read a couple of
conversations with him and um you know I
was his chief whip so I'd like to think
by the time we get to a vote out of
cunningly persuaded him that he actually
needs to vote for the deal are you
optimistic that you're going to be able
to succeed in persuading him
um well Boris is a is a law into himself
in many ways but he's a he's a great man
A wise man an honest man and I believe
he'll
come to see that it's a good idea you
say he's an honest man the privilege
committee is investigating whether he
misled parliaments over partygate is he
a man of integrity yes 100
um because of course if he's found to
you have misled Parliament
do you think that is going to impact his
career do you think it'll happen I don't
think he'll be found to have Mr
Parliament I didn't when I became his
chief whip it was we're just uh all this
all this uh pass gate stuff had started
um I saw him behind the scenes I know
exactly what he's like
um I do not believe for one second or
knowingly Miss Ned Parliament you don't
believe it but
passion to whether he is found of misled
Parliament by the Privileges committee
and I have to say the evidence that they
really so far suggests it's trending in
One Direction I I think he you in this
country you're innocent until you're
proven guilty and I think that um I I'm
absolutely convinced
um Boris did not only Miss Lead upon
um allies of Boris Johnson have uh
thrown a bit of mud should we stayed in
the direction of Sue gray who of course
was leading the inquiry into Parliament
from the Civil Service she's now going
to go and become Kirsten's chief of
staff is that problem
um
no I don't I don't think so I think it's
actually this is where um care can help
out uh his his new chief chief of staff
by just publishing all the messages and
things he might have had with her at
that point in time I've dealt with Sue
gray as a in the Northern Ireland office
as a civil servant
um I see her as a woman of Integrity as
well so I I have no issue with that and
I think here could clear clear this up
in seconds by saying no there's no this
is this is what we talked about at that
time there was nothing there's nothing
to see here she'll know a lot of secrets
about your party though won't you I'm
sure she was the head of propriety and
ethics
um so uh she will know quite a lot about
individuals but
um
she is I truly believe she is a lady of
Integrity so I'm not worried by that
okay
okay I just want to
often cook before we end leaked WhatsApp
messages and Daily Telegraph show he
wanted to use a new covered variant to
frighten the pants off everyone and make
sure they complied with the rules
um can you understand why that might be
quite tough reading for people who found
lockdown very difficult yeah I mean I
read I've read the the piece myself and
it did actually mention
um that the New Kent variant had already
you know there was a thousand cases
um but
the problem with uh this particular
story is that we're just seeing a
partial account all the time now there
is a independent inquiry that's been set
up that has got access and will have
access to all the evidence that's
available so I actually think we should
probably wait and see what that inquiry
is it appropriate to conduct so much
government business on
someone
um well so again we're in lockdowns and
you how do you communicate with people
email um official channels so but every
decision would have been recorded
officially so but I mean what you're
seeing in in these messages are probably
thought processes behind things uh that
you wouldn't not wouldn't normally see
but again they're completely partial of
a moment and that's why we need to wait
for the whole inquiry to report did you
uh do a little check to see what what's
UPS you've been exchanging with Matt
Hancock
um I will do now you've mentioned it
might be why
okay thank you very much for being on
the program uh today Christine Harris
there my pleasure